gestern beim gipfel im kanzleramt ist
etwas ungeheuerliches geschehen
zum ersten mal in der geschichte der
korona pandemie hat sich merkels um
runde explizit mit kindern und
jugendlichen beschäftigt ja nach all den
auto gipfel geht es plötzlich um die
belange dieser mini menschen
kinderpsychologen waren schon zu viel
aufmerksamkeit sei nicht gesund für
deren psyche die haben sich ja jetzt
anderthalb jahre dran gewöhnt dass man
sie komplett ignoriert also verstehen
sie nicht
kinder kamen schon irgendwie vor in
berlin
aber dann halt so auch die möglichkeit
im sommer bis zum ende des sommers im
dritten quartal im laufe des dritten
quartals alle zu impfen
über 60 und unter 60 okay nur die kinder
noch nicht nur die kinder noch nicht nur
die kinder noch nicht nur aber das ja
deren problem für 14 monate kinderknast
im prinzip ohne dankeschön das ist auch
eine klare botschaft
junge junge junge aber der gipfel
gestern sollte die wende bringen jens
spahn hatte sogar eine große
impfkampagne speziell für schülerinnen
und schüler angekündigt so jetzt hat
sich allerdings herausgestellt
zusätzliche impfdosen gibt es dafür
nicht so wichtig sind die plagen dann
auch wieder nicht
dafür gibt es diesen schönen satz kinder
und jugendliche können dann ab dem ende
der priorisierung haben sich auch um
einen impftermin bemühen ja kinder
bemüht euch halt endlich mal und stellt
euch ganz hinten in der schlange in den
usa und in kanada werden über
zwölfjährige übrigens schon seit wochen
geimpft
ich weiß ein kontroverses thema
einerseits haben kinder nur ein sehr
geringes risiko selber schwer zu
erkranken
andererseits hilft jeder geimpfte gegen
neue mutanten und ein steht ja fest bis
zum nächsten schuljahr wird die zeit
knapp
deswegen müssen wir uns für den fall
einer weiteren welle auf die rückkehr
von distanz und wechsel unterricht
zumindest mal vorbereiten
ja ich weiß voraus planen das klingt
total verrückt aber
es wäre schon schön wenn wir im herbst
vielleicht solche bedrückten szenen
nicht nochmal sehen müssten schüler
fallen aus dem zweiten stock auf der
suche nach dem wlan zum xten mal an
dieser stelle jetzt endlich luftreiniger
für alle klassenräume besorgen ja
natürlich aus peter altmaier 600
milliarden hilfsfonds für die wirtschaft
wurden bislang nur 4 milliarden
abgerufen
wir könnten also für 5 196 milliarden
luftreiniger kaufen und allen schulen 5g
verpassen
spoiler wird nicht passieren gibt es
alternative ideen liebe schülerinnen
liebe schüler
kopf hoch wir haben einen wasserdichten
plan fürs nächste schuljahr luftreiniger
teurer quatsch echter digital unterricht
science fiction nein wir haben was viel
besseres vergesst homeschooling erwerbs
ist skimming heißt nach den sommerferien
kommt ihr alle ungeimpften gute alte
internat wo er unter euch bleibt und
keine erwachsenen mehr infizieren könnte
klingt hart aber wenn ihr 18 seid dürfte
er wieder nach hause
und wie eltern müssen solange halt
irgendwie ohne euch klar kommen hilft ja
nix
[Musik]
eben müssen wir durch die paar jahre die
diskussion über das kinder impfen geht
jetzt erst richtig los in deutschland
und ich prophezeie das wird eine sehr
emotionale debatte wie gesagt es gibt
auch seriöse gründe das ganze nicht
übers knie zu brechen sagt auch die
ständige impfkommission die stiko nur
mit seriösen gründen halten sich die
meisten impfgegner ja gar nicht mehr auf
zum beispiel bei telegramm wo scheinbar
alles erlaubt ist und wo sich für
menschen in gruppen frei erfunden horror
geschichten erzählen müssen wir sagen
zum beispiel in deutschland von
geimpften säuglingen in kindergärten die
dann daran versterben
obwohl die impfstoffe hier in europa ja
noch gar nicht für minderjährige
freigegeben sind
umso schlimmer dass damit die erfundenen
säuglinge in den kitas tod geimpft
werden
andere behaupten die einstichstelle am
abend würde magnetisch so was nie wieder
den hausschlüssel verlieren gegen
bauchgefühl und zusammen gegoogelt
deshalb wissen haben fakten eh keine
chance
und wer sich zum beispiel eltern unter
dem hashtag wir lassen unser kind nicht
impfen zusammentun dann will ich mich
gar nicht über die lustig machen
wirklich aber die zwingen ein
jeder der diesen impfstoff an unseren
kindern verhindert gehört ins gefängnis
ich habe fünf wunderbare glückliche und
gesunde kinder und damit sie das bleiben
bleiben sie ungeimpft neun hunde
wunderbare kinder ich habe leider noch
keine kinder aber hätte ich weise ich
würde sie nicht
lassen ich lasse mein kind nicht in 5
warum auch sie ist kerngesund und soll
es auch bleiben lassen unser kind nicht
impfen
wir machen durch bis morgen früh und
singen bums fallera was haben die denn
geraucht wenig erfindung in der
menschheitsgeschichte haben so viele
leben gerettet die das impfen von pocken
über polio bis corona
trotzdem war das eben wahrscheinlich
nicht die letzte derartige hashtag
aktion
ich habe drei wunderbare glückliche
kinder mit gesunden augenärzte behaupten
jetzt mein viertes kind brauche eine
brille
was wissen die schon außerdem manche
dinge sollten kinder gar nicht scharf
sehen können zum beispiel claus kleber
und seine verdammten lügen presse
nachrichten
ich sage immer wenn du corona nicht
sehen kannst kann corona dich auch nicht
sehen
[Musik]
ich lasse mein kind keine brille tragen
warum auch noch diskutieren wir über
priorisierung in wenigen wochen wird es
heißen wie überzeugt man die erwachsenen
impfmuffel in den usa arbeiten sie jetzt
mit anreizen
da gibt es zur impfung lotterielose
kostenlose donuts sogar joins in
einzelnen bundesstaaten vor allem
evangelikale amerikaner sind trotzdem
sehr im skeptisch und hören sowieso nur
auf einen experten genau auf ihn hier
eher das sind diese kulturellen
unterschieden wir hören auf christian
drosten die hören auf gott und auf
diesen prediger
ich rate den leuten zu bieten sie sollen
gott fragen was zu tun ist gott ist
mächtig und wenn du bist und der heilige
geist rät ihr sich impfen zu lassen dann
lass dich impfen wenn er die arbeit ist
zu lassen dann lass es aber lass dich
vom doktor im himmel beraten
blöd mailbox sie sind schon wieder ein
des heiligen geistes
wenn sie eine frage zum kämpfen haben
sie die einst wenn sie einen fall von
kindesmissbrauch in der katholischen
kirche bilden wollen keine zeit reicht
in deutschland am ende für die berühmte
herdenimmunität eine impfpflicht will ja
keiner bleibt die frage wie überreden
wir bitte unsere im skeptiker zum higgs
laut umfragen jetzt wird es interessant
sind dass mehr frauen als männer
erstaunlich
wir schalten wir live auf die instagram
seite von tina hausten sie versucht dort
als sogenannte influenza den frauen an
die nadel zu kriegen tina warum sind
mehr frauen als männer skeptisch nun
universelle und töchter hat weiß dass
jungs normalerweise eindeutig die blöden
sind aber hier holen die wir zur
abwechslung mal den pokal gutes
marketing ist jetzt gefragt ja ich muss
mir aber auch erst mal in ruhe die
argumente der anderen seite anhören und
sie noch mal ernst nähmen
zehn haben und ich weiß ungefähr das ist
schwer zu sagen das kann ich jetzt nicht
sagen
wie schade was war jetzt genau das
argument dass sich ernst nehmen muss
weiß ja auch nicht ist auch nicht der
punkt die zu überzeugen skeptische
zielgruppe ist laut studien überwiegend
weiblich gebildet und verfügt über ein
höheres einkommen oder ganz wertfrei
formuliert wir reden hier von nervigen
öko ein wenig arbeiten müssen und
deswegen zeit haben den ganzen tag
erfundenen bullshit im internet zu lesen
ja viel wertvoller kann man es nicht
ausdrücken und wie kriege ich die ja nun
zb mit einem ansprechenden produktnamen
ich sag nur astrazeneca es klingt wie
ein kleinwagen von opel geht gar nicht
nennen wir es also aroma zimt annika und
das wird dann achtsam verimpft und
nachhaltig jetzt übrigens auch in light
nur noch zwei kalorien pro dose ich
kriege kein corona und nehme ab und
darauf fallen im skeptikerin rein
ja wenn nicht dann gibt es ja noch einen
anderen bewährten tricks zum frauen
produkte fertigen stadt bei montech
nennen wir es bei montech lady werden
die ampulle rosa und machen sie zehnmal
so teuer wie die für männer geht weg wie
warme mutterkuchen so jetzt reicht's ich
höre mir dieser frauenfeindlichen beck
war mal üben keine sekunde länger an
mein name ist der haus nie schnellen
dingeldey und ich bin antiken flur ins
rennen
weder werde ich hier oft noch mein
wunderbarer sohn sören der jury denkt
nämlich noch selber der würde er sich
nie ins lassen ich würde mich sofort
impfen lassen
matschie nämlich konsequent verschwiegen
wird ja impfstoffe dringen in den
zellkern und fordern können sie gar
nicht verändern unser erbgut und machen
unsere bar
sören gandalf und ich mache nicht mit
bei euren gen experiment wer sich
nämlich bei den richtigen quellen
informiert der wsl gibt nur eine art und
immunsystem wirklich zum boosten
muttermilch weiße gold wert den jungen
ab heute wieder stillen
syrien bleibt hier geht um nehme dort
wörter hosten
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
mime hersteller
wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß und liebst -
wollt dann abonniert jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist mina hersteller
[Musik]